you
all the members and offices working to
be what the district council commander
committee will start off on during the
emergency evacuation should we move like
to evacuate the building is you please
leave the building by the news available
exit to the Taliban our simply point
will be the pub car park at 76 sweet
please do not be writing your evacuation
to collect any belongings please do not
return to the building I'm still giving
permission to do so by council star
please now that this meeting will be
audio recorded canals are glitches we've
got our bottles that you have on silent
or switch doesn't please welcome to the
first made another developer community
fitness musical year members of the
public are reminded that this is an
official council meeting and the Artemis
cultivated according to the regional
council rules apply to Catherine to
which the public are omitted members of
the family are not permitted to speak at
this meeting unless a previously
registered to speak with member services
in this way anyone
here is the council's will be able to
make an informed decision agenda item 1
apologies for absence cancel American
counselor in you popped gender eyes of
tone so character class 11 and sameer in
our home substitution forever okay can't
a sniffly substitute and some good deals
cancer Williams you're substituting for
councillor Marek and council Stanga is
substituted for cancer newport we will
be covered them on agenda items we are
there in non members attending place
that's the drive to drive japanese of
this gift that's okay thank you your
name is a great the needs of the meeting
held in the front first of april two
thousand sixteen very good keep getting
around five do any members having
interest to declare generally
benefit of new members this evening if
you are a very salsa and we may wish to
declare an entrepreneur interest by
virtue of being a
compare notes submitted on objection to
this application you're reminded that
you are here in the district cats are
not safe and sound counselor and you
will listen to all the officers
presentations and public speaker and
debate on the floor and you will need to
consider this application using material
considerations within your district at
all thank you
by that basis sorry is chairman and you
need to see if there's any bikini chest
I interest place remember
okay thank you on the other hand okay
okay thank you say okay in droves of six
reason that the planning application for
the land of west of out road north and
haul road blocks that has been withdrawn
the agenda for the meeting agenda item 7
application under $16 165 if you will
blank rear of 103 high road rated board
members are cancer Burton Dre and drifty
and Katie Rogers represent get the scoop
up
so your channel this application is for
subdivision of an existing residential
plot the erection that one detached for
method of the site is at the corner over
high road and glasses vein and this this
area colored red is the application site
with an area adjacent colored blue which
is in the control of the same applicants
but does not form part the application
site members will see I'm on the tests
on screen that the ultimate referred of
the week of this and the reason skipper
were relating to the impact on number 1
plus is lane which is just to the right
hand side of the site here due to over
development overbearing nature of the
moment homes this is shows an aerial
image of the application site which is
the very part of the residential garden
of this property that fronts high road
this is the name of property number one
Gus is slain at number three joining it
the Senate I prepare
the floor plans of the proposed
development show have been internal
damage and it's not me Squire layout and
at first of all here you have for
leggings 4-bedroom property and note
that there's no registration pose at
first law or indeed at the ground door
on the right hand side from 22 cata
which would be adjacent to the wild
PLATUS name the bits and fenestration
upon floor on the other side running
both functional and first floor to a
sterile and that would face regards
married the property lists to the men on
the site this is the design of the Ponte
which features a hip roof to decide
which would be adjacent to the
neighboring property bond casters late
and then enable ended here it's a dual
pitch to the front elevation and we
continue in total value to the side this
is the elevation here that would face a
number one bus is waiting there with
with no fenestration on that elevation
so the sighting of the dwelling is sent
within the plot with a rear guard has
been closed to the rear and parking to
the fund a new vehicle access will be
created on to grasses lane to the front
of the site small area be retained for
landscaping yeah and the site will
accommodate the two parking spaces on
the driveway for back in planning in
addition to the internal damage which
would be an atom so the key
considerations are the only have dated
proposed development on wore glasses
they in particular and given a list of
the nearest residential policy in terms
of overlooking offices aren't concern
that this young development and what
caused over looking to number one given
that there's no fire station for posted
side the mistranslation proposed to the
rear a planned for one first floor but
we consider that the relationship those
windows which would face directly down
the garden or be able to give permission
for some degree of overlooking without
their garden it's not a new relationship
in a in a standard discrete setting in
terms of overshadowing into we have a
policy recommendation to do with first
floor extensions it doesn't specifically
relate to new buildings but it's a rule
of thumb or use it as a guide which
takes a 45 degree angle from the nearest
ground floor habits for windows so the
middle ground floor comparative front
elevation on this proxy here and if you
take the 45 degree angle the two-story
element of the proposed whaling doesn't
double breach that and again at the rear
the proposed running will be set
slightly forward of this neighbor such
it wouldn't cause overshadowing that
would be considered detrimental in terms
of the layout of the site the proposed
value importance provide war me to
separation to fight values that the
counsels argument requires a minimum
will just provide the 21 street parking
spaces across the internal damage
hundred square me to the garden gnome
provided to the new prophecy and in
excessive this would be retained for the
property to remain there is no highway
objections message county council
subjective to a condition which
we'll see at the end of the
recommendation for this is apropos
streets easel sincerely we're both
learning some context here Yusei vs
chael is similar to the service hatch
pairs taken together which is shown here
one was one and three with it the
relationships Tesla and that's the
church aliens would stumble six photon
and one additional dwelling of the
proposed assigning form we consider to
be appropriate another party having
regard the existing character the street
we are posting an additional couple of
conditions supplementary to ones that
are reported on the Wii tennis to do
with soft landscaping so we were to
require a condition as with the band
between the market you can see in the
photograph here that the existing
fencing is kind of standard clothes
boarded one point eight HD meter high
fantasy obviously some of that would be
taken out across the frontage providing
access and it would be more appropriate
to Hubble there was that I've found a
treatment to this call at five
visibility splay so that will all be
controlled by condition in addition
obviously members can see them awesome
and established trees and beg arm in
this property at least these two here
wouldn't be able to remain given the
proximity of the dwelling to the side
boundary but this one closest to the and
southeastern corner which is that it
could remain so in relation to our
policy DM 25 we recommend a condition
say that that shall remain and that
appropriate fencing at that
protection during construction and
should be in place unless the applicants
put forward an agricultural assessment
that says for some reason this cars in
which case we will requiring the
replacement trees we put in that place
to continue some visual amenity to this
breathing so the recommendation chan of
the subjugation is that the committee
results they should be approved subject
to the recommended conditions on the way
they stun from the additional ones thank
you thank you we have a public speaker
and Christopher star
here you have we had five minutes sir
you're wondering if it's money oh good
evening my insist Mustaine and my
property is number one glasses like I'm
grateful to have been given the
opportunity to address you on this
matter I'm attempting not to be an
amendment my opposition to this pairing
application is one of the shears going
with on such a small plot and the
dramatic effect that would have on
number one this application is proposing
to build within one meter of my boundary
and a forward projection from our front
building line of four meters the height
of the building is one point three
meters more than my property and this
will cause lots of light outlook and
overshadow in the planning officers
report that i read online it makes it
cleared the property will be adversely
affected their his words not mine this
forward projection of four meters is
being put forward under the 45 degree
rule this world taken from the corner of
my building by 45 degrees
he's going to be a very close and open
when I look at among you know what I
will see is a wall which I don't see at
the moment and this like to come from
the planning officers report again
business everything online the 45 degree
rule applies to extensions and not near
both in economic why it's useful tool to
assess the impact on neighboring
properties another loss to understand an
application that is being built around
the rule doesn't apply to you bill no
clearly sounds the 45 degree rule
applies to extensions of not new verbs
if this week this would be granted i'll
be faced by sheer two-story wall
projecting 4 meters forward of my house
one major from my boundary and 1.3 meter
up higher than the prop my current
property you can imagine what it will be
live who's standing at your front window
which is less than a meter from this
point of which the property is taken I
mean it's just going to be able my
lounge has got fireplace on that wall
which is next to the bit so we're
sitting is arranged it slow therefore my
window is there when you sit here I will
see a wall you come
this brings me to a matter of light I
believe that number one has prescribed
right right under the 20 year old my
understanding of that is if by windows
about unfettered life for more than 20
years they have a right to keep it the
Royal Commission report on right tonight
says natural light inside buildings is
immensely important for comfortable
living the amount of natural light that
we know that in depends on what is
outside the window and the proximity of
other buildings I consider that this
building would infringe my right to like
under these terms and should your
decision go against me I wouldn't have
to consider seeking an injunction in
this respect glasses Lane is a
well-known cut through which already
causes trouble to exit the property by
car home our consider that building such
a high density property of all that
Marchetta will only late in congestion
occurs at this junction all the trees go
is before the new I have suffered from
flooding due to the height difference
between our properties of water that
these trees have gotten of some concern
these trees have been there before any
development in glasses lane I asked the
committee to eject this application and
perhaps some advice could be given to
the applicants the child cart with a
building in scale with the small club
than having regard to the building lines
the 10 30 high road the number one
glasses like a swarm up bundle I might
be nice i'm not doing in me and thank
you for your help in this
Oh
bahrain non members of the committee
would like to speak louder any committee
members of our speed on this application
houses standing
shall we feel at shoujo cool allen Smith
counselor step to the council and
Christine Mason counts not talking about
him going out so Chris then
members
kenna smith please Thank You German at
the top of this application it says
White House ward which was the former
war that I represented White House no
longer exists the District Council
purposes sir so this is something that I
was engaged with prior to the last
election this application in many ways
is technically compliant with a lot of
what we what we say we want from a
highways point of view though this is a
very busy location the nature of the
junction with jairo means that when cars
turn into glasses leg either when there
are approaching the wear or coming up
from really where the speed is very high
and if you have if you're at all
familiar with that particular location
number one is that it is a difficult
place to get out of this location would
be even more challenging there's also a
high fence line 2103 high road along its
board with glasses lane and that would
make things even more challenging from
visibility displays but as members all
no highways it's not an issue that we
can take issue with because as its
highways doing this be compliant but I
think those comments still need to be
there make in many ways if we were to
look at this purely from 103 Tyrone's
viewpoint we might consider it to be a
backbone of a background development but
it's not it's fronting onto glasses lay
and as such it should be considered as
part of glasses lane
I think it's a diagram six where we were
able to see the line of houses a long
glasses lane and what we can see in that
diagram is that this proposal is
significantly forward of the building
line it's not just number one but number
357 and so on it's quite true to say
that there is a drop in the elevation a
lot of glasses lane and if you take a
number 103 high road as the high point
then move down glasses lane there there
is a drop but the proximity of this
application to number one and number
three glasses Lane mean that the the
actual high mine is somewhat overbearing
if we consider the actual for the
position of this one I think that the
the appearance of this being prominent
onto the onto the street scene of
glasses lane on with it it be I will say
a landmark location but a lad but a
location it is that the the front of of
rayleigh a location that many people see
as the end to the town i think that this
will have an overbearing nature i think
the the plank wall that we've seen a
boat and have windows will have an over
their name of overbearing appearance and
impact on number one i think overall the
this this property with its building
line means that it is out of keeping
with street scene and i think overall
the loss of amenity value that
that is it imposes on numbers one and
three mean that it is something that is
not acceptable and on those grounds I
would move refusal thank you thank you
cancel stepped out here United seconds
of the lesser picture I just took what
splat pressure from a picture and the
projector mentioned that the new bill is
someone leaked from the boundary what
distance is it from the actual house
another one it looks like as a driveway
between the two assembly you have to
refer to something I'm not heard of
before 20 min order to the right of the
lights could make interpretation on that
I must know whether that can be consider
them at your own private motor that's
not matter for the phones and played
probably has what the rights to
challenge that and that vegetable matter
that you do that to the PI system so on
that basis is number two come here okay
that's correct yet
distance yep so that when scouser four
meters from the edge of that building so
you've got the wall needs their three
additional meters cancel Christine
message thank you scare the people i
commented is unlike educational three
points that face many offices firstly
bother any windows in the side of number
one best lesson buries it that my face I
get where that faces the proposed
building
you could on the phone operator and
nothing to tell you though
this
on the line with the trees on the
previous diagram also wrote a place with
trees whether it's post building is
going I'll learn your windows from the
existing building not 10 free jairo but
we have the other side the one that's
shown in your diagram I really we nose
on that side on this side elevation here
yes I don't it's not written into the
office report but i think i got over
here and the gentleman over there and
the test the door windows on that side
elevation now there aren't there are
sorry and i think those are info to
trust window because it's a cycling
because i wanted to know them or
anything thank you for that the second
point which again it's really concerned
isn't clear and the officers report and
hasn't been cleared from the
presentation is that I understand the
slope of this land from what I've been
hearing the slope runs down from the
high road towards the new building
towards the objects are building we make
all of that I've got thanking the
elevation there now if this is one point
three majors higher is this this is a
slope that's actually on the land yeah
so it is it's the site there is a slope
downwards a long massive lane so this
building up the 103 which is on the
application site is on a higher than
level and then they rode sloped
downwards and that direction sounds
lovely and so this roof here would be
approximately 1.3 meters higher than the
ridgeline number one could you confirm
that one point three meters high built
or 1.3 meters high it doesn't take into
account the slow yes because otherwise
it could be fine there's a pointless
that's the final built for on-campus a
final book book thank you and the other
question that I'd like clarification on
it settle it with the entire garage it
says that the dimensions below the deck
requirement garage is to be considered
as enough to accommodate the vehicles
puppy space as well as household so what
is the depth that is normally required
for these and that interests me so we've
got three quite surprised which one are
you there's an eternal eternal to read
was approached work life i frequented by
this is the loan debt requirement well
it's the death acquirement over to cash
the partner space and is there a meter
deep and the Deaf hear own internally
will be 5.5 to the desperate with my
sister to show ya thank you Oh what I've
heard and what I've read and i had read
this report quite thorough mr. chairman
there's just a lot of little bits that
are quite right because i'm in my
attorney and as has been commented is
compliant with our policies and our face
value if you read the report it would
see that they're the reason for approval
is given when you do put all the little
bits in here is are not quite right the
number of issues that caused concern
I certainly sadly that the funk and mass
of the building and that's obviously a
consideration is rather overbearing but
then it comes a different picture and
I'm bearing you mind we had a recent
training limiting where we would hope
that if things are advised that it
thinks there are lots of reasons perhaps
that you need condition cats we should
refuse so on with the information I had
and the concerns I had a victim fans I
would support refusal okay thank you can
imagine why's that counselor Smith work
as official speaking mention highways
and I'd actually made a comment about
that and I accept that off the ECC is
doing is okay but from the from the
annapolis or of the the property of two
parking spaces they struck me that would
be very difficult for a vehicle to
safely exit the property in the forward
position and if I concerned about cars
having to reverse on to a main road
that's something can also be considered
I was a very should also too if you
could mean some response to the 45
degree wall and whether this can on me
it is only applicable for exceptions and
not new bills that could be considered
so the 45 degree rule is written into an
supplementary planning guidance that
sound policies in the m1 so much number
30 their fortified rules specifically
relates to first floor expansionist
evocative so when it comes to a new vyel
property it is a judgment on each on
each case on its merits on the
characteristics of the site and
proximity appointment properties as to
the impact that the development would
have on amazing property other as a sort
of rule of thumb we utilize the
45-degree ball to establish to some
cement sources of parameter for the
extent of the shadowing and in this case
that 45 ground has been taken from me
that the point of the wick the start of
the window closest to closest relative
it isn't it's that 45 degree is breached
in this case but it's it's a judgment
about
yep in light of the fact you saying that
it's there's a certain flexibility when
we are here to that certainly with a new
build and we are we able to in terms of
reasons for refusal to acknowledge the
comments that have been made regarding
the impact that that would have okay
it's a lot of thumb and that's just it
we've been using the new to the new
running that we explained in during the
sessions that we can see relations it's
part of that weight isn't it and it
might problem why that we is one thing
you look at but then it sounds normal as
anything else would be something else
with them the whole new building with an
extension it's more it's more clear
because you're building on an existing
structure that you can't actually
located in the site itself with a with a
new bill it was way of doing that most
entrepreneur in terms of making
commentary that it's you know and to a
in a report or with regards of
commentary with it in terms of Prayer
well actually lose weight around dealing
with that problem through moving
buildings and changing building sight
lines so as X that's why it's not
actually part of policy for new films
because it would be too early to strict
it because actually what we want is a
good overall development so it's it's a
lot of sort of rule of thumb things we
tend to use but it's not it's not a
collective using she directly for having
northern plants in terms of this place
Italy what you said before words that
dominance that size that mustn't normal
issue then therefore practical
the same yes sir most of it's been
already commented on I just found it
about parking coming off of the front
garden where you probably need a double
driveway to give but you it would be
obscure when coming reversing out so
there is a concern as that is used quite
considerably so reversing onto the micro
feet in joining our forwards is going to
be a difficult operation and you
couldn't set up the road because of
where there is another point is if I
believe this is there is 10 rock so is
there a telegraph pole somewhere along
that route there which might even
obscure to the driver's ability to sing
yes very there is yeah them is it might
be object it's just awful yes I know
we're going to treat on this boat it's
on this corner yes it's just office is
image here a year ago either it would be
adjacent to me it'd probably be adjacent
to just the edge of this soft I'm
staying area that would be odd being
retained it for big the lives that foot
to the side there would be a requirement
going in the defensive cuz we control
that that will all be lonely
so although that would be if the
telegraph pole remains in this place you
think you'll be able to see round it
given that all of this we require to be
open the funding spot you promote me
with another thing that happened
reasonably to preston gardens in
relation to invisibility we had a speed
saw in clark and ponies needs only six
inches in diameter The Telegraph bugs
that's are bigger and you we had it
moved because the visibility at the road
you couldn't see quite clearly from your
drivers position or from the front of
the car from the drivers position you
couldn't sing at the road so are we
obviously I don't think that they speak
the same Telegraph of the writers room
for millions latency as an actress yeah
Thank You Sherman up I have some
sympathy with an opponent full cheezle
things among the web's overbearing and
massing I feel free family are beyond on
my life has of them being bird's-eye
views gives a good few a lot of other
countries in the bird's eye view you've
done okay yes what I'm looking at those
what we will hear the being part of the
new property on number one but if you
look two houses down you've got number
five which is almost identical to number
one yeah and that's got numbers right
next to it which comes very slightly it
comes slightly forward a number five
amazing you go out and get number one
these number seven this slightly forward
or number nine but I'm wondering how
about going to you if you can go further
down downstream pizza slice a fix Calvin
since I've been eating these two
dissimilar all the way down just one ago
if I can focus using a little bearing I
think the chief factor maybe these
feelings and bearing from the new
property significantly greater then live
in the bering model of MBP the
announcement further down the road but
now I suspect the east later I thought
the top part tell from the picture how
far forward number five is deliver fees
for the number seven and one of the five
personage but interesting to know but I
generally I think blank wall will number
one about his death registration and
understand was no penetration but it is
a pretty Billy music album into going to
the starchitect with bad intentions so
I'm inclined to entities bottom it
though how far forward number please
comparing number five is up the bus the
bench transmiter
3 the applicant has shown on their block
plan and some of the properties for
Pratap them perhaps show house showing a
footprint of these two and stay off that
planet does the right number three is
certain approximately two and a half
meters no we just a reasonable I'm not
the plan shows it's about two and a half
meters but why would a plan that plan
doesn't necessarily have to show that
word is not hot down patient site and
also if there is any return a greater
separation between those two those two
planets that there would be the case
between the proposed an adult or more
that's about that easel with basically
so i unbind conclusions that we
overbearing this old post office even of
the war is significantly later than the
impact of months of selenium right
thank you for going back there was one
item that there I forgot to mention
getting carried away with another three
another wall the actual relationship
between this new property and 103 high
road is something just like very small
for a moment clearly we haven't held
anything from wild 103 but we wouldn't
really expect to because it's in it's in
the back garden we've not been too
worried before about back to side
relationships and properties but I'm not
quite clear what the exact distances
with the real 105 and the side this new
new proposal I think that might not be
ideal thing at it in any other
circumstance and as we are always
striving to put in high quality houses
and not to put but in relationships
between properties that are detrimental
I think that is something that that
relationship is one that's been
overlooked but in the back of online
something to consider when we do look at
the reasons for a few summers i'll be
happy to restate
anyway it's just got a couple questions
for the offices and in relation to the
building within the perimeter stated
that the distance pursuing side of the
building and the offense 90s is 1 meter
is that the minimum that is the absolute
minimum so it's on the minimum
requirements
and if you put up again about the the
overhead view with the fried green line
from from that drawer and it looks like
it is either right on top of that line
or slightly ahead of it so from that it
likes it looks like it's slightly
breaking that 40 degree rule or or
guided shows act on the it might just be
the vp image and I think what this shows
is that kind of the roof over half of
the wall over the two-story side element
shown on a lot of plan and it is not
breached as I shown it is it on the
bodies it's all about so it's
everything's on the limit in relation to
issue thank you
click crescent moon court says that the
outrageous hundreds coming to garden
area is that the backs but does the back
on by itself deploys I'll just square
meters or including someone like Jerry
heels you go back to the original Dark
emotion I know the Thunder picture of
the house with the trees yes yes when
looking at the side I can see that the
true lining between the two properties
it is that what's the difference between
the light deprivation between the
existing tree structure to the building
which is going to be erected
yeah so so I'm obviously honest in this
image taken as a five year and that the
three-volume leaf and then I visited
sites a day and obviously you claim you
can see me again the 290 in relation to
this is fancy but the that we would ask
this tree remained anyway I'm given it
it's got some immunity value to the
street these would go but the dwelling
that was a place it would be a meter on
the boundary probably the impact in
terms of overshadowing the way from the
dwelling to be provided because given
that these would join waiting on some
moves a little bit more light impossible
to include leaves when I was Captain
Smith to somebody please Thank You
chairman I'm pleased that there seems to
be a degree of concern about this
application my reasons for refusal
they're probably providing wilder to
take on top on three on three points the
overbearing mass and nature of the
proposal on number one the impact on the
street scene particularly the building
line had been out of keeping with and
thirdly the loss of amenity lots of
amenity it to the area generally
poonam all your attention to our policy
d and one which is Nanami development
and too many parts of that policy which
would bring attention to which is
Evelina's chance to learn review that
come up with some reason reasonable
reasons refuse around your comments yeah
and that basically said the design
redevelopment she should I'm promote the
character the locality to ensure the
development possibly brought resource
foundry natural environment and the dish
humility that discouraging original
innovation work oriented design and
layout of the postmark must understand
following have been carefully considered
and addressed from the proposal the two
issues I think that we can picked up
very clearly in terms of the poverty
late relate to certain remedy nine which
is avoiding a good-looking ensuring
privacy and promoting visual clarity and
let also the wrist um there's ten
removal 10 which has a positive
relationship with existing buildings in
accordance with on Cydia three if we
then obviously and also um in terms of
Roman numeral eleven scalable approach
to locality in line with policy DM three
quarter dm3 we can then pick up issues
around which sounds in filling and
message intensification closes for it
fitting religion transportation or back
under must demonstrate the following a
bean-counter considered possibly address
another benefit and Romania more on one
design of the proposal
an agent existing Street pattern and
then Stephen locality its enormous you
left street scene and to the number of
the types of our we're the number one
type of noise being proposed are
practically locality having our existing
character but could that meet the answer
we enforce weddington around those most
those policy considerations of that
fulfill mr. Chairman I must admit to not
having done my homework as soon as I I
should have done all my reasons for fuse
those other anticipating being on the
the other the other ventures are not
coming to go through that little detail
I'm quite happy with my sofa state
sponsors two managers are in character
Street hand and an ever so folks they're
bussing and and then looking more I'm
scared form approach to a cartoon
running
ok grab to the boat just go focus just a
first second if I castle yeah okay all
those inside that has recommended by the
committee the sharp ends three key
contributors pops out of your future
yeah was it too nice carrot initiatives
that in terms of image is amazing that
you're pretending
this is
Oh